[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday january the
27th
2022
my name is freddie gray i am the deputy
editor of the spectator and i will be
your
host on the show
we will be discussing the apparently
never ending crisis that is boris
johnson
can the prime minister survive i will be
talking to james forsyth katie balls and
gavin balwell about the politics of
today
after that we will be moving on to the
pressing geopolitical matter of the
ukraine i'll be talking to owen matthews
and dmitry alprovich and we will be
asking if vladimir putin really is going
to invade
and if he does invade
is the west really obliged to step in
and stop him
i will be talking to the fox news host
tucker carlson
next up the markets there have been
highs and lows and a lot of volatility
is going on on wall street and across
the global financial system i'll be
talking to bloomberg's joe weisenthal
and asking what on earth is going on
finally we'll be talking about the
etymology of the word based
a word that used to mean getting high on
crack but now has come to mean being
fundamentally conservative
i'll be talking to grayson quay about
what the word based actually means
before we get going a reminder that if
you like watching spectator tv please
subscribe to us you can do that by
clicking the link at the bottom of your
screen and then tap the bell icon as a
reminder so that you never ever miss an
episode and while you're at it why not
subscribe to the spectator magazine it
is the greatest magazine on earth after
all
you can now get 12 weeks of the magazine
in print and online along with a free
20-pound amazon voucher for just 12
pounds
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take that
offer up
first up the ongoing saga of boris
johnson's premiership the prime minister
is now facing not just one but two
investigations
into the various parties and rule
breaking that took place in number 10
during the covid
crisis i'm joined now by gavin barwell
who was chief of staff for theresa may
in number 10
as well as two of our political team
james forsyth our politics editor and
our deputy politic politics editor katie
balls
gavin i will come to you first do you
think boris johnson's problems have got
worse or better in the last week
my senses his long-term problem has got
worse if anything the polling in terms
of where the public are has deteriorated
a bit
but i think the immediate risk has
probably abated slightly
and why do you think that is
so i think that the
the police investigation uh has helped a
little bit i think the argument around
russia and ukraine
uh that this isn't the right time for a
leadership election is having a little
bit of traction with some mps
uh the 22 obviously backed off changing
uh the rules about how frequently that
there can be a no-conference vote so it
seems to me
the immediate pressure he's under right
now has very slightly abated
but the number of issues that are
bubbling away and the underlying
anger in public opinion mean i think his
long-term
uh prognosis hasn't changed at all
james do you agree with that i mean i i
think
it's clear that among the ukraine issue
has made quite a few mps feel a bit more
hesitant about knifing boris i'm not
sure public opinion would be necessarily
the same
i think the police investigation means
that things are going to move more
slowly but they are ultimately more
serious i think one of the best
arguments or one of the only arguments
that the
boris johnson supporters had left was
look you know this would be a
disproportionate response
this doesn't rise to the severity of
things that a prime minister should be
removed over it's not the kind of
failure of the central policy of his
government which is normally what does
it does for prime ministers but i think
the fact that the police are looking at
it
makes that a more difficult argument to
make because people say well you can't
say it's small if the police are
involved in investigating it
and so i mean that does make things more
difficult i think the great uh we're
recording this on are on thursday
morning the great unknown is
when does the supreme report come out
and what form does it take i think if it
comes out in in in something close to
its kind of full form uh then i think
there is a then i think that the we will
once more be back to a conversation of
whether the 54 letters which would
trigger a vote of no confidence are hit
but if it comes out in
a redacted form or if it doesn't come
out for some time
then i think that things will slow down
and wait i think the other thing that is
working for boris johnson at the moment
is uh he is taking a more kind of he's
coming out swinging he's always at pmq's
on wednesday he's attacking kierstama uh
and kiestarma is not
asking the right questions and that is
and so boris johnson is you know he's
showing some fight which is has
reassured some tory mps i mean that
becomes much more difficult once the
grey report comes out because he will
then have to do two emotional registers
in the same statement he will have to
both show contrition but also show
uh some fight and trying to balance
those two things will be it will be a
very hard political juggling act
katie uh the word criminality is used
quite a lot uh in very sort of serious
tones uh how uh
realistic do you think it is
uh that the met will find criminal
uh acts have taken place within within
downing street
so i think it's a strange one this week
because in a way we know very little but
we do know a few things and ultimately
we know that a police investigation has
been triggered by evidence that sue gray
has uncovered the cabinet office sent
evidence to the met police that is why
they made that announcement earlier in
the week
which tells us the report is going to be
more damaging than boris johnson's
supporters thought it would be a few
weeks ago they were suggesting that
there would be no criminality and no
evidence suggesting that and clearly
things are worse than they expected in
terms of where this goes i mean i think
it's worth pointing out as many uh tory
mps who think they're being helpful to
boris johnson have that ultimately were
you defended behind guilty of you know
breaking the covered guidelines it'd be
a fixed penalty notice so there's
something well if boris johnson or one
of his senior members of his team or his
partner had to pay a 150 pound fine
is that really you know the end of the
world
but i think it then goes to the point of
well it doesn't look good if you're
being investigated by the police is
boris johnson going to be interviewed
under caution that would be seen as a
big step
um and how long does it really run on
for so i think it's more about what
boris johnson has said has he misled and
then what is the long-term impact of
getting various stories in the coming
months of figures in downing street
being interviewed by the police but
until this report is out and we can see
its contents it's really hard to tell
which way this is going gavin i think i
think some tories are starting to see a
way out
for the prime minister now because
um if he can sort of wriggle on wriggle
out of these investigations to a certain
extent and then point towards uh the
declining covid crisis take as much
credit as he can for the booster
campaign and the vaccination rollouts
and look at some signs of of good news
in the economy
he can start to paint a better picture
of his premiership
yeah i think it's clear that the only
strategy number 10 has got here is to
play for time exactly as you said and
hope that
as time goes by public anger is going to
abate i'm i'm personally skeptical about
whether that's going to work you know i
think you can say well look if the
police did find him guilty it would only
be a fixed penalty notice the problem
he's got with this issue it seems to me
fundamentally is that lots of the things
that go on
here in sw1 don't really cut through to
public opinion but this issue really has
and it has because everyone relates to
it because everybody
remembers what lock done was like in
april and may and june of
2020 and there's huge anger
at the fact that the sacrifices people
made and it appears that the prime
minister and the people that work for
him weren't playing by those rules so to
me
you can go through all the sort of
mechanics of what's going to be in the
grey report and what the police
might do
but ultimately i think you can add into
that equation are we going to get
further leaks from there's clearly been
an orchestrated campaign of leaks so are
we going to get more leaks after the
grey report
but to me if i think back to my time
with teresa you know she had a vote of
confidence against her because the main
policy that she was trying to deliver
was deeply unpopular in the party she
survived that ultimately the thing that
made her position impossible was the
collapse in support for the party
once we hadn't left on the 29th of march
so i think ultimately the prime
minister's fate is going to be
determined by public opinion if you look
at the polls at the moment
62 percent of people are saying he
should resign 25 are saying he shouldn't
his net approval ratings are about the
same as jeremy corbyn's before the 2019
election if he cannot raise those
numbers
then ultimately the conservative party
is going to make a change at some point
between now and the next election and
the question is when so
yes you can play for time but that only
works if you think public opinion about
him
is going to abate and shift over time
and i am
well you know polls can't tell you that
one way or the other but i'm skeptical
because of the way i think this issue
really cuts through with so many people
in this country
james how do you think tory mps are
feeling do you think that um
uh they're starting to sense that public
opinion might be starting to get
exhausted with partygate and people just
want to move on
well as one tory mp said to me that the
their email inbox has calmed down but
that's they think largely because people
tend to write in the first 10 days of a
scandal you know if you haven't written
in the first 10 days you're unlikely to
do so
i i think the
may elections have become even more
important forest johnson because that
will be regarded as the kind of first
electoral test of what impact this
scandal has had on on the party
i also think that tory mps
have gone and and this this is i've got
to that point where everyone has been
very quiet um i was talking to one mp
who's he's been in parliament since 2010
and they have written their letter
and i asked them if their friends had
done so and they said i haven't even
asked my my kind of closest friends
whether they have and they haven't asked
me that so there's there's a real
silence there and also i think it's also
hard to tell the numbers because you
know uh there's a there's a hundred plus
strong support group of boris johnson
being formed as all these things are
investments these days on whatsapp but
there are several members of that who
don't really support the prime minister
so there's there's a kind of
you know
people the polite way of putting it is
that the tory party is the most
sophisticated electorate in the world
the the impolite way of putting it is
that you know you don't believe anything
about what a tory mp thinks until you've
got kind of four forms of independent
verification of it and i think that
makes it quite hard to judge the mood at
the moment
and where things are
katie
there's a there's a sort of widespread
theory i think everyone believes it
really that this has been a an
orchestrated campaign
against boris johnson i'm sort of
steadily dripping out uh details of
parties and rule breaking
do you think there's going to be a
another big bang and a new
revelation coming up that might
make the crisis even worse again
yeah i think that is the fear of many
mps and quite a lot of the mps who are
wavering who don't necessarily really
want to go into a tory leadership
contest right now and would like to
muddle along are worried that what will
stop that from happening is this drip
drip of stories um some of which are
coming from dominic cummings on his sub
stack others of which are appearing in
the press and i think this sense that
more could come out it's worrying people
i i suppose it feels as though if and i
think some of the public are getting a
bit tired of hearing endlessly about
parties almost a threshold for shock
has to rise and therefore i think if
there was something like a photo i think
that's one thing that's worrying mps and
there's talk that see gray has been past
photos of parties and downing street i
think something visual like that could
be what brings the story back to life
for lots of people so i think that
that's a worry that it's something which
um for some who have calmed down and
stopped writing to the mps is something
which
further advances it and confirms
people's fears
gavin james and katie thank you very
much indeed
next up let's talk about the rather more
grave matter of the ukraine in his cover
piece in the magazine this week owen
matthews says that he doesn't think uh
vladimir putin is going to invade
ukraine and we are in the business of
phony wars
i'm joined by owen now and dmitry
alperovich who is co-founder of
something called the silverado policy
accelerator institute based in
washington dc
um owen i think it's fair to say you're
skeptical uh about the reality of the
imminence of this conflict i think you
think that um
putin would like to invade ukraine and
has intentions to do so at some point
but now maybe not the time is that a
fair assessment of your
analysis uh no i don't think he wants to
invade ukraine um the my argument is
very simple that actually um
um
he needs to be extremely desperate uh if
he's to invade ukraine because it would
be extraordinarily risky and basically
an act of economic and political suicide
um he may find himself in some future
date in some future circumstance
actually forced to do that if his back
is to the wall but he'd have to be
extraordinarily desperate right now he's
doing a different thing
kiev is essentially something of a
bystander in this process
putin's message is aimed towards nato
it's about nato's engagement with
ukraine ukraine itself is not really a
player in that process at the moment
therefore invading ukraine will not
solve his problem his problem is he
wants to make it very clear and draw a
line in the sand that further nato
engagement with ukraine is dangerous
it's a geopolitical threat to russia's
national security he wants to
demonstrate that
that nato is divided
and most importantly i mean the most
important data point
that suggests that he's not planning any
kind of imminent invasion is that such
an invasion would be a very hard sell to
the russian public
uh i mean recent polling shows that 66
percent of
young russians are under 24 because in
other words exactly the people who would
be expected to fight a war
actually uh
uh
responded there positive or very
positive about ukraine
a land war in ukraine is a very
difficult cell the russian media are not
pushing that line yet it's very
different situation from 2014 where
there was an absolute barrage of stories
about the alleged genocide against the
russian-speaking population and so on so
for that reason putin is not preparing
his population for a land invasion um
the message he's insisted many times
that he has no intention of invading
ukraine he's made no demands of ukraine
he has no three he's made no threats
against ukraine what he's done is he's
deployed
a large number of russian armored
divisions around the borders of ukraine
um but as the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky said on friday
the situation essentially hasn't changed
and has not become more serious over the
last year
so
it's not entirely clear to me why
everybody in the west and especially
among western pundits is convinced that
the
that putin is planning an invasion of
ukraine in february it's a mystery
he's not in any way
talking about it or preparing his people
to do it
dmitry if i understand your position i'm
not sure i understand people's positions
anymore but if if i understand your
position uh you would disagree with what
owens just said
yeah i would strongly disagree i think
invasion is highly highly likely to
happen in the next few weeks and for a
number of reasons so one the deployment
of forces that have taken place is
really extraordinary and unprecedented a
huge number of
italian tactical groups have been moved
over
you've now had a deployment that was
unannounced
into belarus
ostensibly for a rapid exercise that was
never planned and the types of equipment
that has been moved in not just the the
tanks and artillery
but
bridge building equipment
you have engineering battalions you have
air defense systems that have been all
moved to towards ukraine we now
basically have a uh full complement of
uh forces um almost ready for for a full
invasion at least of eastern ukraine and
then the other thing i would um disagree
with owen on is this preparation of the
russian public i would say that the
russian public did not want to go to war
in chechnya in 1999 it did not want to
go into syria in 2015 it did not want a
war with georgia in 2008 um and
despite all of that of course putin had
uh engaged in those conflicts and turned
the population around in support
of those conflicts um in part because he
was able to manufacture uh pretax like
the the one in 1999 uh where you had
apartment bombings that took place all
over russia they were blamed on chechens
still unclear whether it was actually
chechens who did it or not but
nevertheless that instantly mobilized
opinion and i think you can do that
again where uh you know potential
shelling of a russian village on the
border of ukraine that you can blame on
ukraine forces and some deaths uh taking
place would immediately change uh enough
of russian opinion to justify an
invasion in a way similar to what stalin
did in the winter war in 1941 where he
shelled his own soviet village um and
blamed it on on the finlands uh finnish
forces and uh um started the war
oh and i'll i'll bring you in
does putin have to act
um absolutely not he's um uh i i find
that very um strange logic dimitri have
to say i mean to to say that he has to
invade ukraine because otherwise he'll
have to come back with his tail between
his legs he's not asking ukraine for
anything he's not making any demands of
ukraine his demands are of nato he can
invade ukraine and not your greater pain
that doesn't fix his problem as i said
before the the the the process that he
started i would agree with you that
there's uh the urgency and the
prominence and the vociferousness with
which lavrov and putin have actually uh
made this play uh about about nato
expansion um are unprecedented the
message obviously is very familiar
i wouldn't agree with you that the
troop deployment is unprecedented
because or certainly um uh vladimir
the president of ukraine doesn't agree
because he says that the situation has
not is not substantially worse than it
was last april when the last uh
deployment
buildup
uh uh occurred on ukraine's borders
um but the point is that actually um
what he wants is not in ukraine's gift
it's in washington's gift and he's it's
in nato's gift and there's a tremendous
amount of things in his arsenal uh both
uh
diplomatic and uh practical that he has
to run through before
the idea of actually war comes to
the the forefront
in any way shape or form i mean for a
start here he's
done extremely well from his phony war
just by moving heavy metal around inside
his own country he's got everyone's
attention he's got everyone in
washington among the ponderotocracy very
scared
biden is actually offering he is offered
another summit which is the kind of
superpower theater that putin absolutely
loves and revel and excels in uh macron
has been talking about uh
uh
reviving an eu russia subbing which had
been michelle for a long time
he's actually got
the the
british defense secretary is due to go
to moscow and he's actually got
everyone's attention and he's
demonstrated just by
rattling his saber already an extremely
important thing is
that nato is
very deeply divided about the issue of
engagement with ukraine
it's united in its message that
sanctions
if he does invade ukraine will be
devastating they're united about in that
but already just by rattling his saber
he's already demonstrated very clearly
that there is deep disunity and deep
nervousness among many nato members
particularly in germany about further
engagement much less eventual membership
for ukraine and that's exactly what he
wants he's already got something for
nothing
dimitri do not think it's a bit odd that
uh
the ukraine
ukrainian leadership
seem much less concerned about the
invasion of ukraine than a lot of people
in the west in london
and washington do
i don't and uh of course the ukrainian
leadership changed dramatically on this
point
in just about a month's time because at
the in early december they were at least
a military there's the defense minister
and other
intelligence ministers were talking
about the fact that russia is about to
invade and they were talking about the
forces that were being deployed and and
uh were begging the west for help and
now that we have even more forces
rolling in now that we have the
diplomatic track basically um going
nowhere and the russians saying that the
the concessions that the u.s side has
brought to the table in geneva
and in uh brussels uh during those
negotiations are not sufficient the
ukrainians suddenly are saying well
there's no threat at all um what has
changed what has changed is that the
ukrainians are starting to realize that
the west is not going to be um
supporting them that there's no prospect
of troops uh what nato troops coming to
ukraine's aid in fact western nations
united states and others are pulling
people out of their embassies and
they're very afraid that it's going to
cause panic among the ukrainian public
zelinski
president zolensky of ukraine
has a very
tenuous
control on power is very unpopular his
ratings are in the 30s if russians do
invade he will fall
almost immediately
so he is very concerned about all of
that his main rival poroshenko just got
back into the country despite the fact
that he's facing uh a prospect of an
arrest and um trial for treason
that is not an accident uh i think
poroshenko smells blood in the water in
the weakness of zelensky and sees an
opportunity for him to to make a play
and all of this reminds me dramatically
of um just about six months ago when we
had
very similar pronouncements from the
afghanistan government of that uh that
of ashraf ghani also saying that
don't worry taliban is not going to take
over the country and then making
pronouncements about how they're not
going to take kabul and there's going to
be a fortress kabul and then hours later
leaving the country
i think we're seeing a very similar
situation play out in ukraine
unfortunately dimitri and owen uh
there's a lot more to be said and it's a
very fascinating subject but um
unfortunately we have to end it there uh
thank you both very much for coming on
it's a great honor to be joined by
tucker carlson who is host of tucker
carlson tonight
which is a show on fox news but also
available in the uk
uh or through the fox news app
and we're going to be talking we're
going to continue to be talking about
the ukraine
um and tucker uh i think it's fair to
say you've encountered quite a lot of
criticism
in recent days because as far as i can
figure out you are the only
mainstream host
who is skeptical of the idea that
president biden
needs to interfere militarily
if vladimir putin invades ukraine
and for that you have been called a
russian spy
a russian asset
democratic politicians have said
that you are um your viewers are calling
them up to tell them that you're on
russia's side
how do you answer this charge that you
are on the side of an evil authoritarian
with the chuckle
um
but what's interesting
is
the presumption in the united states is
that it's
you know terrible to be an asset of
russia but
entirely acceptable to be an asset of
ukraine
and and many of course in washington are
the president's own son worked for a
ukrainian company and the president
himself was deeply enmashed in the
internal politics of ukraine when he was
vice president and of course still today
and i'm not sure why that's better
you know no one in the united states
ought to be an agent of a foreign power
or
promoting foreign interests at the
expense of america's interests i mean in
a democracy it's very simple the
government exists to serve the people
who put it in power by voting
and your foreign policy ought to reflect
that which is to say your foreign policy
ought to serve the interests of the
country now if it's ancillary effects or
improve the lives of others then that's
that's certainly grave and virtuous
but if its primary goal is to
serve the interests of other countries
or their populations then it's by
definition illegitimate i mean that's
the you know that's the role of church
groups and ngos and you know there are
plenty of humanitarian organizations but
the us military united states state
department the white house the us
congress even our media
exist for the benefit of the united
states period and they've lost sight of
that and that's the promise the argument
i'm making against
intervening between ukraine and russia
we already have by the way we've said
billions in what we're now calling
lethal weapons
as opposed to what i suppose but
missile systems and small arms and all
kinds of stuff
to ukraine into neighboring countries
you know we're already funding a proxy
war
so
why would we be doing that i mean is
there a vital american interest that
serves perhaps there is i haven't heard
anyone explain it
and you sort of know if they go
immediately to you're working for
vladimir putin or something i have like
a limited interest in vladimir putin
i've never been to russia i don't speak
russian
much less ukrainian it's just not a part
of the world that is captured by
interest but even if it had to answer my
question
right i mean like what is the vital
interest at stake and of course they
they can't answer it so they go ad
hominem immediately to me that's a very
obvious sign
of their weakness if you become
hysterical when someone asks you why
you're doing something then maybe you're
doing the wrong thing
well perhaps there's a certain
insecurity about nato
and particularly among
in britain i know
there's a strong desire to sustain nato
even though the primary purpose of nato
to win the cold war has gone
and do you think there's an argument a
legitimate argument to be said that if
we allow uh putin to expand into eastern
europe into non-nato powers then he will
be
buttering buffering up against
uh nato powers that we are committed by
treaty to support and america is
committed by treaty to support so
it puts
russia and the west
at a sort of trigger point that they
aren't at the moment
okay well i i mean i guess but that
would be a voluntary trigger i assume
i mean i think it's important given that
the soviet union collapsed when i was on
my honeymoon that was 30 years ago i
mean the full collapse happened in
august of 1991 that was the point it was
my and my father worked for the us
government waging the cold war so that
was at the very center of our family's
conversations every night
at the very same moment that many of
these now russia hawks were making
excuses for the soviets i should point
out irony of ironies but in any case
it was a secular regime then it's a
regime that subsidizes the orthodox
church now so maybe that's the
difference
just to guess
but but in any case
at that point
you know you think someone say okay we
have all these post-war institutions
that have i think very effectively maybe
even valiantly serve their purpose they
kept the soviets from invading western
europe that's great
i was always for that always for nato
but at this point what is their purpose
maybe we repurpose them we recite we
have a standing army called nato so
maybe we do something new with it
but no one ever
kind of articulated what the new purpose
is
and that's a huge problem if you have i
mean this is a thing something that you
know anyone who covers washington where
i was for 35 years sees every single day
these zombie institutions marching
forward toward what no one will ever say
their original purpose has either
disappeared
or they failed to achieve it they've
been proven ineffective at doing what
they were designed to do but they
continue because they're well funded
that's fine if it's the head start
program which was designed in 1965 to
raise the iq of poor kids it didn't work
but we still have it
but if you have an army if you have a
military alliance called nato
i don't know that could be really
disruptive unless you have a clear goal
i mean this used to be prerequisite for
all military action
define articulate the goal make it very
clear to all participants that's what
we're attempting to do
imperial japan we will not stop until
you proffer and we accept your
unconditional surrender they wouldn't we
dropped the atom bomb on two of their
cities okay got it now you could agree
or disagree with what we did
but the goal was never in doubt it was
unconditional surrender so what is the
goal of nato exactly
to protect ukraine it's not a member
i mean the whole thing is so
so so crazy and childish i
anyway you see that if i mean if as as
some people suggest one day you might be
if you were president of the united
states would you say let's scrap nato
you know as it can as an instinctive
conservative i'm against breaking things
without a good reason so you have i
think the first thing i would do with
assassin's creed so we have this thing
we have this military alliance
it's awfully well funded
and awfully well armed relatively
speaking
and is there something useful we could
do with that and i and i think it would
be
worth pausing i have not i've been
thinking about this for you know fairly
intently for four years since putin
three and a half years met with
trump in helsinki i was there and this
was this was a a big topic like what's
the point of nato and i have not met
anyone who could explain how we could do
something useful with nato
um
does anyone sincerely believe that
western europe is at risk
of being invaded by putin well if it is
then
western european nations which i think
we at this point can trust to have
weapons
should defend themselves i mean that's
the idea of the nation state you defend
your own interests you have a vested
interest you have what we call skin in
the game and you want to defend it if
it's worth something to you
and that system has kind of worked
fairly well
well i mean i don't want to sound like a
i don't want to sound like a hawk
because i don't think i am but i mean i
suppose the theory would be
if let's say putin somehow takes over
ukraine which again is is doubtful
uh he would then be
up against the baltic states some of
which are uh
some
nato members so what how would you how
would you
deal with that would you say that if he
invades a baltic state does that become
a different question i would i'm not
sure i would deal with i mean as from
the american look i'm an american
i have no other passport i've got four
kids four dogs in a house i'm not going
anywhere so from my perspective is
wholly american and i think every
country has a different perspective
that's why i was from brexit you know
and each country should be able to
represent its own perspective on the
world stage that's like a baseline view
for me so from an american perspective i
would say is it you know given the
competing nature of interests
is it in the top tier of interests to
prevent russian expansion in eastern
europe i mean it's not something you'd
wish you want free people to live in
freedom on the other hand the freedom of
people's threatened the world over there
are ongoing border disputes in africa
the continent that i'm actually
interested in
that have been you know
going on grinding on causing the deaths
of literally millions for decades and
you know that's sad nobody wants it to
be the case but is it in our interest to
physically prevent it or try to we also
have a terrible record of actually
affecting the desired outcomes
we just withdrew from afghanistan
this fall after the longest war in
american history and rather than pausing
to ask why didn't that go as expected
what are the mistakes we made what are
the assumptions that led to those
mistakes were on to you know
contemplating an invasion of russia
during winter
because that works anyway this is very
interesting
i would ask the question like
the clearly the the threats to the
united states and the uh our interests
global trade routes energy
pure like military power relative
uh relative military power comes from
china of course
and so to the extent that you are
focused on another region given the size
of our military our attention span the
limits of our budget you are detracting
from that and so the question is is it
worth it
and being american we're not trained to
think that way we imagine everything is
a possibility the world's a menu of
endless possibilities we could do all of
it
but the truth is we can't never have
been able to there are limits of you
know physics and money and
and reality that impose on you and so
of course i wish latvia the best i would
feel sad if latvia ever lost its
autonomy to the extent it actually has
autonomy as a nano member but whatever
i would say to myself
you know that's sad is it
but is intervening given the realistic
possibilities of doing what we want to
do worth it
given that that would detract from the
real problems which are east
not eastern europe but far east so
that's how i would think about it i
think that's a pretty moderate
sensible realistic way to think about
anything i don't think that's radical i
certainly don't think it's taking
putin's side i have no
i have no special interest in any of
this i only care about my country
well it's interesting you mentioned
china because
there's a lot of talk in foreign policy
circles about the pacific pivot over the
last 20 years in america and how
america's strategic focus now has to
move to the pacific rather than to
europe the middle east
and eastern europe
of course the pacific pivot does
actually challenge china i mean it does
challenge china's ambition so
it does presumably suit china for
america to be focused
on uh the ukraine
because it means they care a little bit
less about what china's doing in say the
south china sea or something like that
needless to say
so and you could you know look i'm not
alleging any conspiracy here i do think
there is a feature of human nature
that causes and i think it's innate that
causes people when confronted with an
unsolvable problem to turn to something
else
to occupy their minds
and anyone who's been i mean this is
relevant to your viewers who are
journalists anyone's ever been on
deadline for say a magazine piece will
find himself surely tempted to rearrange
his books by author
because it's it's another problem to
work on as you ignore the problem that
confronts you that you actually can't
solve
china is a problem that is very hard for
the united states to solve
and it's not clear how we do solve that
problem by problem i mean
you know sort of giving hegemony of over
the world to a country that doesn't
believe anything really that we believe
it would be a massive change in the way
the world operates in the way that we in
the united states live and the way that
you and great britain live i mean having
china in charge of the world would be
very different from what we have now
that's a huge concern a legitimate
concern i think
um and we're not meaningfully dealing
with it and i think
you know part you often hear people on
the right say well that's because
they're all taking money from china well
yes that's true
our former secretary of state madeleine
albright was like a [ __ ] by the way but
got rich as so many have been but you
know got rich
effectively making china's case to the
american business community many others
in our diplomatic world have done the
same so that's a that's a straight-up
sellout hollywood sells out the nba
sells out they're controlled by the
chinese government everyone knows that
but i think the deeper problem has
nothing to do with commerce it just has
to do with
the terrifying nature of this threat
and our own fear that we can't actually
do anything about it so here's where i
would start
not that i make these decisions
but it's not a question of pivoting east
china has
massive influence within our hemisphere
go to any island in the caribbean
including the american colonies there we
call them protectorates or their
colonies
saint croix virgin islands for example
all the infrastructure in san cros built
by china
what
why would china be building the airport
and the roads in saint croix and why are
they doing the same in jamaica and haiti
and virtually every population center in
the caribbean also true in south america
again
this is our hemisphere
which for more than 200 years we've said
explicitly we control we will not allow
you know world powers from across the
oceans to control you know anything of
meaning in our hemisphere and yet they
are and this is being completely i never
heard anybody mention it
i just noticed it from traveling a lot
so i would just start there and say you
know what is this about
maybe it's totally benign that they're
building the infrastructure in bolivia
maybe it's not well also i mean if if
you were designing american global
strategy you would think if you were
george kennan or something you would
think
isolating china would be good therefore
splitting russia off from china would be
good
except for the fact that america's
rhetoric at the moment seems to be
driving russia to and china together as
as quickly as possible
what's and that is of course the effect
i i personally believe it's one of the
intended effects
but what's so fascinating to me and so
repugnant
is that clearly there are many people in
positions of power in the united states
who sincerely believe that we have more
in common with china and his government
than the government of russia now this
is in no way a defense of the way the
putin government operates you'll notice
i don't live there i don't care to i
feel sorry for ed snowden who's stuck
there etc etc
but if we're being honest and we always
should be
we have far more in common
with russia than we have with china i
mean
russia is a christian country no it's
not any kind of evangelical country or
morally upright country i'm not right
but its culture is rooted in western
civilization which is another way of
saying we never say it but it's true
christian
civilization and christianity i mean its
presuppositions are christian whether it
lives up to them often it doesn't the
darkest period in russian history was
the period when it ceased to be russian
and became soviet
and
you know anyway you see the point so
for our leaders who are very familiar
with how both of those countries work to
look at the world and say
you know
we're on china's side which is
absolutely what they're saying
reveals something horrifying about them
again that's a you could say you know i
hate putin i hate the way he runs that
government
but really compared to what i mean
that's the other compared to what
this is a nasty world
filled with you know genocidal lunatics
at the helm not simply of two or three
countries but of a lot of countries and
the only reason they're not committing
genocide is to zone the power to but a
lot of bad people in charge always have
been
so to decide that putin is the worst of
the lot like you're lying actually or
you're totally ignorant
well you'll bringing up of christianity
and western culture brings up uh another
accusation that is often made against
you which is that you are
uh rousing the forces of
ethno-nationalism
uh how do you respond when people say
that you
hath ethnonet i mean that's one of those
phrases that the sort of half-wits in
charge of the atlantic magazine throw
around without thinking about
ethnonationalism i don't know i don't
even know what my ethnicity is i'm like
half swedish half english i guess it's
not of great interest to me i can tell
you that i'm an american i don't think
in ethnic terms i wasn't raised that way
at all um and i still don't and i resist
all
pressure too
pressure mostly from the left to
categorize myself and everybody is a
member of some community or
racial group i hate that [ __ ] and i will
never participate in it so but i would
say what's so interesting
is that the same people who are saying
you know
opposing war with russia over ukraine is
ethnonationalism are simultaneously
making the case that ukraine is for
ukrainians
and that the russians have have no right
to enter so our country we had two
million
immigrants unauthorized illegal without
documents whatever you call them
commenced this country in the last
calendar year 2021 2 million
that's like four times the size of the
city of boston that's a massive number
of people okay
even in a country of 345 million so a
lot of people unprecedented
and the pre the justification for this
is well borders are racist people have a
right to go wherever they want in search
of a better life
here i'm looking at tens of thousands of
russian citizens masked on the ukrainian
border hoping to get in for a better
life and i'm seeing world leaders say no
you're not allowed to do that ukraine is
for ukrainians i mean speaking of
ethno-nationalism why is it if we can
import thousands of haitians illegally
why is it
such a lift for the ukrainians to just
you know let several thousand russians
in
obviously i'm joking sort of i mean of
course i'm joking
but i also think like that's
that's a ridiculous i mean speaking of
ethno nationals what's the largest
ethno-nationalist nation in the world
well it's their closest ally china
china is an ethno state it's run by and
for the chinese why do you think the
weakers are getting so much trouble why
do you think that you know the
mongolians and the tibetans because
they're not han chinese
so look i i'm not you know you run your
country as you want i'm not really much
of a judger actually i judge my own
country because i live here
but the same people you know bill
crystal was like
he's like an idiot there's no
nationalism fascism okay got it got it
built
a guy who couldn't even run a small
circulation magazine is like i'm in
charge of american foreign policy
think about what you're saying
i mean it's like it's it's ridiculous
and so there are many ridiculous people
i'm ridiculous sometimes i get it i have
a high tolerance for ridiculousness it's
the seriousness with which ludicrous
people are taken that really scares me
we have a big important country you
can't
allow
dumb people to act stupidly
without you know reacting to it it's
like what uh it really freaks me out how
mediocre our leadership class it's not
just that they're wrong
but they're like low iq it's like bill
crystal is considered an intellectual
really on the basis of what
what no
do you do you now deliberately uh
organize your program to trigger their
rage i mean for instance you have
no no no i i don't i mean one thing i do
i i don't and by the way if i'm being
honest
you know i don't have a great sense of
their rage because i don't you know i
don't like the internet it hasn't made
me smarter you know i really i make it
affirmative effort to turn off all the
garbage devices i don't own a tv but i
have an ipad and a phone
you know that's my whole electronics
right here and i turn that stuff off at
night and i read books
you know nothing nothing crazy but i
read you know non-fiction books at night
and so i don't i just don't like i don't
think the internet has made us wiser or
even better informed
um and so i don't go on like social
media i don't know on twitter reading
about myself or whatever i don't really
know
did you let people say and i'm not that
interested if there's something
important someone i love will tell me
and i'll listen carefully but
like what if david frum is mad like i
worked with david frum for six years i
know david frum really well
david frum is mad at me i mean fine
you know what i mean i don't care why
would i care
uh tucker carlson thank you so much for
coming can i just say one thing i i just
always think this i do have some pretty
far out views on a couple of different
things but they're not
related to anything political
yeah you know i have really strong views
about nature or whatever um that are not
mainstream views
however my views on like race or sex or
foreign policy are like
completely moderate
middle of the road you know 10 years ago
my views were not even interesting
enough to mention yes and my views
really haven't changed so it's just so
funny to be like this radical putin
apologist racist
like really no i'm more i'm much more
conventional than that what is your most
far out view
i hate drywall
i i really don't like unnatural building
materials i really believe in wood and
i'm an extremist on the subject and i
won't
live in or spend any time in a room
whose walls are covered with drywall
which is like paper covered gypsum yeah
and it's a very conventional building
material because it's cheap and easy to
install but it's disgusting and it's
it sucks the life out of you it's it's
just innervating to be in a room covered
with trouble so i just won't you know i
won't it's not more expensive to panel a
room with say pine boards like the one
i'm in right now and so i do i'm not
spending any time in a room with drywall
or overhead lighting or anything
fluorescent like why would i do that i
really believe in natural building
materials aesthetics are really
important to me nature is really
important to me
and so i'm just not going to do it you
know i'm never going to stay in like a
hotel room if i can help it i don't i
don't want you so
i'm afraid to tell you tucker as you
probably know
that is your fascistic ethno-nationalism
expressing itself
well it's funny like i'm architecture
really matters to me and when we were in
hungary last summer i gave a speech i
never write anything down so she's
giving a speech and i just launched into
this thing about architecture because i
really care about it
and whatever it's not you know i like
pretty architecture that elevates the
human spirit and not
sort of grotesque steel and glass
architecture that crushes the human
spirit i mean it's that simple it's not
i have no complex or brilliant views on
this at all they're very very normal
views but i really really mean it so i
give this speech and like david frum
what he said to me is like oh he's
albert speer
he cares about architecture he's a nazi
it's just um it's hilarious
uh tucker coulson thank you so much for
coming on spectator tv
thank you freddie it's great to see you
please come on again and uh yeah good
luck with everything
moving on are we on the verge of a
global financial apocalypse there seems
to be a lot of volatility
in the markets at the moment i'm joined
by bloomberg's joe weisenthal who is
co-host of the odd lots podcast
uh joe thank you so much for uh coming
on
uh thank you for having me
great pleasure great pleasure um
there's a big meeting at the federal
reserve which is going up before we
record this which is going to happen uh
after we record this and
it seemed like it spooked the markets uh
in a big way in the last few days but
they seem to stabilize and you have this
very odd thing where markets seem to be
crashing dramatically in the morning
coming back up uh
and it's fair to say there's a lot of
volatility
yeah what on earth is going on
i would say there's uh really two things
going on and they're sort of getting
mixed a little bit um but they're
distinct and so one of these things and
i think the last time you and i spoke
with probably like almost a year ago is
remember like the meme stock gamestop
amc craziness that sort of like gripped
american markets i think that was the
last time we chatted basically a year
ago
that has actually been deflating ever
since our conversation basically our
conversation was the top
we peaked we uh peaked it by discussing
it and we've seen that continue to
decline the sort of like retail frenzy
in america related to like certain beam
stocks certain tax stocks growth stocks
cryptocurrencies has kind of been fading
for almost a year now if you look at the
charts and that's accelerated
over the last few months so that i feel
like is its own story as sort of like
animal spirit animal spirits manias they
go up and then eventually people want to
cash in their gains and then they slowly
come down
then there is this other element which
is that starting you know probably in
the middle of last year
uh inflation in the us
uh really started to gather steam
clearly picked up
that was in the that was last summer and
then by sort of late fall early winter
it sort of became apparent that it
wasn't going to end any time soon people
some people hoped maybe they're like
okay we're going to have two or three
months of elevated inflation then we'll
return to something normal
some point late in the year maybe around
october or november there was some
recognition that it was going to persist
for longer for whatever reason and
that's when we started getting noises
from the fed and they've continued to
accelerate or it's like okay in 2022 it
is likely we are going to get multiple
rate hikes and the easy financial
conditions that have characterized uh
the uh the environment um throughout the
pandemic might start to uh come down a
little bit some attempt to rein in
things and i think that has uh hit the
market over the last uh over the last
several weeks
what is interesting is that i mean as
when we spoke about it before the real
the real threat as far as people who
knew about the markets was con were
concerned last year was retail investing
that there was a sort of retail mania
which essentially means people like me
taking a punt on something just because
it was a bit of fun
and uh there was a bit too much money in
the system and it was all flowing
towards bets on the stock market from
the the common man
uh and
actually what seems to be happening in
recent days is that it seems to be if
i'm correct me if i'm wrong it's the
retail investors
selling off dramatically in the mornings
perhaps thinking about their tax burden
or worrying about inflation
and then it's the institutional
investors that seem to be coming in and
picking the market back up is that a
fair reading i think i think there's
definitely an element of that you know
it's hard to know i think there are a
lot of
non-institutional
individual investors who still have
religion about i'm gonna buy every dip
but i'm going to every time the market
goes down just put a little bit more
weight that exists but i think look uh
you know the sort of the the person who
discovered
markets in march 2020 maybe when they
were stuck at home and they're like i'll
download an app and start trading
this is probably the first time that uh
this may be one of the first times
they're experiencing real downside
volatility they may still be sitting on
personal gains that they want to lock in
that is an incredibly powerful force
like people have this idea like i'm
going to be the hero
who uh buys the bottom and makes a ton
of money
but
in reality you know let's say you
invested two thousand dollars and you
ran it up to twenty thousand dollars
maybe it's down to ten thousand dollars
now you might be thinking oh i kind of
like locking in my gains that's ten
thousand dollars i didn't think i was
gonna have maybe i would just sell some
and so the the psychological impulse
starts to turn and everyone no one wants
to be the hero anymore and people just
want to uh lock in their games so i
think that's a real thing that's
happening right now
well something you see at the sort of
the furthest end of this speculative
mania i suppose is cryptocurrency which
i know you're very
which you're very interested in
uh
and it seems to me as somebody who has
uh
as a victim of speculative mania had a
dabble in cryptocurrency
you see this sort of cult like behavior
in in the markets which is if you don't
hold you are somehow almost sinful you
have somehow betrayed
uh the working man to the system
uh and that you have to hold even if
you're losing what precious few games
you've got
do you see crypto as a sort of
extension of the mania that gripped the
markets yeah 100 and i think the way you
characterized it as the person who
either sells or refuses to buy it in the
first place is perceived as almost being
a heretic as being sinful i mean the
word no coiner exists it's essentially
like the word atheist and so like you
have to like create an epithet to
describe the person who refuses to join
in and the stronger ones the currencies
that have held on the best and all of
them sold have the strongest cults have
the strongest uh internal belief systems
and the ones that have fallen the most
have like
maybe a meme which is like a very like a
poor man's version of a cult it's just
not enough to sustain it but yes you see
it absolutely where there's extreme
disdain in the bitcoin community for
years they've had this um
this term called rage quit which is when
someone who has long been a believer
um uh announces that they're leaving the
community and often is one of the early
developers they'll write something wrong
and let's say bitcoin is not going in
the direction i anticipated when i got
into this blah blah i'm walking away
from it and they're like the true
heretics they're lower than in the in
you know the outer rings in the deeper
rings of hell they're deeper than the no
coiners who never began the people who
saw the light and then walked away and
so there are these extreme cult religion
elements good and bad sinful morality
that sort of like help govern because in
the end there's nothing there look you
know it's like a stock right like you
buy like shares of coca-cola you don't
really need people to believe in it
because coca-cola sells something it
produces earnings and the earnings in
theory flow through to the shareholders
no belief is required uh to hold it when
they're when you have assets that are
almost strictly uh speculative in nature
or the future is very speculative the
only thing that guides the price is
where the level of belief is at any
given moment
well finally joe uh i'm going to ask you
something you probably don't want to
answer this question i'm going to answer
anything slightly vulgar it's a slightly
vulgar question but i imagine a lot of
our viewers
will be slightly concerned about what's
going on the markets and thinking what
they should do
um it seems to be a very difficult time
to uh maybe i'm asking this question
just for myself and my limited
uh resources but what i mean what
what what what the people you're talking
to where are they thinking that is a
safe bet for their money in this very
uh tumultuous time that we seem to be in
you know i i would start by saying every
time it seems really hard look 2020 was
one of them and 20 the first half of
2021
are some of the most extraordinary
periods for market gains in history
and we had a pandemic and then we had
this uh
the the most fraught electoral handoff
we've ever had in the united states
which you know on paper like that's not
good for markets it turned out none of
it mattered but there are certainly
plenty of reasons why someone might have
been scared out so it's never easy but
look and i don't you know i'm not gonna
give advice
but i would point out
that
the sort of like it's very boring but
the sort of like bread and butter by the
index s p 500 you know put a little bit
of money into each paycheck and not pay
too much attention to it it just keeps
going up and so like there's a great
chart you know like um
uh the
this fund arc that was like just nailed
all the uh tech stocks from 19 uh 2019
2021 it just crushed the market it's now
basically over the last two years once
again even with the s p 500 after
outperforming it massively for years is
just that slow and steady it seems to
work i don't know what's going to happen
in the future and it's very boring and
no one wants to hear it and everyone
thinks that oh yeah well i if i buy now
i must be buying in at the top because
that's my luck right but it seems to
work out okay in the long run for people
who have just had the discipline to be
boring
or you can invest in warren buffett's
which i know you've pointed out on
twitter
it's boring and it's it's not sexy
but these strategies that sort of the
experts say work i'm just like buy
something diversified
it does seem to do okay
yeah if in doubt buy concrete that was
the best yeah buy concrete a little
copper some government bonds and maybe a
company that makes fun to probably
alright
joe thank you so much for coming on uh
thanks for having me
finally we are going to discuss the
curious case of the word based
uh it's a strange word that seems to
have materialized online and i imagine
quite a few spectator tv viewers will be
unfamiliar
with what it is but to explain all i'm
joined by grayson quay who is the
weekend editor at the week
grayson for the uninitiated i think i
probably include me in the uninitiated
can you tell me a little bit about what
based exactly means
uh
where it came from
and then we'll move on to the brow over
it
sure so based uh originates on the u.s
west coast in the
kind of drug subculture as
it's related to the idea of freebasing
or smoking cocaine um so it was
originally describing someone who was
essentially high on crack and acting
very erratic as a result
from there the next step in the
evolution of its meaning was
you weren't necessarily high on crack
but you were acting like you were
a similar thing would be trippin or
tweekin or wilden or just you know
you're crazy
uh which can be spoken dismissively or
with kind of uh a sense of admiration
right
so
there was then a rapper who became
prominent starting kind of in the mid uh
2000s
uh named little be the based god who
kind of appropriated the word based for
himself and took it to mean being
yourself not caring what anyone thinks
living out loud so to speak um you know
oh man that guy's based that guy's crazy
he doesn't care what anybody thinks he's
just doing his own thing
um
and that's what got picked up in the
mid-2010s uh especially with the rise of
donald trump in the u.s
as a sense of being contrarian of being
not afraid to tell it like it is and not
afraid of the condemnation or derision
that that would draw upon you
so it became a sort of uh i mean
other
uh peop pilled was it was an expression
it sort of meant something similar to
that i mean you sort of you sort of saw
the world clearly from a from a
conservative or some people would say
far right
perspective
yes exactly it did certainly become
associated with the right particularly
with kind of the very online pro-trump
right that's been kind of variously
characterized depending on on which
outlet and which think piece you're
reading
we could probably call it the alt-right
which was a slightly out-of-fashion term
sure yeah that's a that's a weird term
to me because it depends like some
people it just means you know i don't
agree with liz cheney uh or
and then to some people it means i'm a
white nationalist so it's it's a term
that to me i've kind of stopped using it
because it's it's just so loaded in
different ways depending on who you talk
to
but then so as as the trump presidency
went on uh the word based sort of came
to be used more and more uh online and
it seeped a little bit into other media
as a way of showing approval so you know
if i if you said something that i
thought showed you you hated the libs i
would say
that's based
and uh people would like like it and
chuckle to themselves online
um but there's a new revolt uh
on the online right against the word
base because they feel it's sort of been
incorporated by the normies or by the
slightly lame center right say
yeah so based kind of had this sense of
being contrarian or being almost
trollish but then it also took on this
idea of being based in or rooted in
something that's something usually being
kind of
uh western tradition or truth or
something you know beyond the the
endless flux of liquid modernity right
um
and
now what's happened though is there's a
new site that's launched in the u.s it's
apparently pretty successful last i saw
they were getting you know six-figure
numbers of page views uh which is good
for a startup i would say
it's started by two journalists named
brad palumbo and hannah cox and they
call their site based politics
uh now what caused the whole
stir here is that palumbo and cox are
both well known as being libertarians
they're both certainly right of center
but they're very well known as being
libertarians
and uh there's this sense that these uh
these coke-funded corporate shills
are now trying to appropriate what it
means to be based
right and so so uh journalists like the
writer saurabh amari have vowed never to
use the word based because it's moving
away from a sort of catholic
traditionist revival and towards
um
you know the kind of republican party of
the 1990s is that the idea
i think that is the idea yeah if you
talk to kind of the post-liberals or the
new right or the catholic integralists
or whatever you want to call it um
you do get this sense that you have
progressivism on the one side and you
have kind of right libertarianism on the
other side and that these two ideologies
divide the world between them and they
both enjoy painting themselves as the
scrappy underdog right if you talk to
the right libertarians you know the
government is is run by uh socialists
right and and big government is the
biggest problem we have and then if you
talk to the progressives right the
government is run by right libertarians
and the biggest problem we have is that
everything's laissez-faire economics and
we don't care
uh about about the poor about regulating
or anything like that
and sort of the post-liberal response to
that is that
this is uh this is a sham fight as i
think gk chesterton put it about the the
two-party system of his day
um
that you actually um have these two
ideologies dividing the world between
them they're two faces of the same coin
two heads of the same beast
and that the true uh dissidents are you
know themselves the post liberals uh so
for someone to try to so for someone who
is part of one of the dominant
ideologies even if it doesn't
acknowledge itself it's as such
to try to paint themselves as based as
contrarian as rooted in something
outside of the here and now
to them is you know deeply offensive
there's uh there some of them may these
people don't tend to believe in cultural
appropriation as a concept but there
have been plenty of jokes about that you
know your culture is um or our culture
is not your costume that sort of thing
yes it's quite funny that the word based
uh should be sort of taken i mean it
sort of belongs with uh libertarians i'd
say because as you as you point out
earlier it originated as a term for
getting high
uh it's it's not something a concept
that you would naturally associate with
the traditionalist very moral socially
conservative right
yeah i think there is a sense of being
kind of there is a sense of being
iconoclastic of being a little bit
trollish there that i think helps
account for the adoption of the word
based by this
um by this group that does tend to be
more socially conservative and and
um
less amenable to kind of moral
libertinism
but at the same time i mean this is just
the world we all live in uh you know
woke um is a term that originated also
in the the black subculture um
you know you have the idea of uh being
canceled
that i remember kind of coming up a few
years ago
as something that people would say in
these very catty twitter spats and now
you know we have
prestigious think tanks having uh
having symposia about uh what it means
to be
canceled and we have uh french academics
talking about lewik coming to destroy
their society
uh grace finally can i just ask you what
will be the the new word have you seen
any new words bubbling up on the horizon
that will be co-opted
by libertarians in years to come i'm not
sure uh i've heard i think uh matt
purple told me this which i've i've
discovered that you your surname has to
be a color if you really want to make it
at the spectator world you know great
great green and purple right um
you've got the you've got the first name
almost covered yeah yeah um so he
he said that uh he's her keyed as in
like keyed in or keyed up to something
uh could be a potential replacement for
baste i haven't seen it much yet so
we'll have to kind of see where that
goes
i like it
uh you you heard it here first
and that's it for the week in 60 minutes
for this week
if you thought that episode was based or
even if you didn't
please subscribe
you can do that by clicking the button
at the bottom of your screen and then
hitting the bell icon at the top to make
sure you never
ever miss an episode
that's it thank you very much for
joining us please come again next week
[Music]
you